so yeah my main goal in this talk is to
basically introduce a different way of
looking at parallel computation and
convince you hopefully that one needs to
look at communication complexity at
least as much as computation complexity
so this is a little bit of evidence that
communication is the more important
thing in many cases for those who don't
know since 2004 clock rates on computers
have not increased so the only way to
actually get more computation than is to
get many computers and there are many
examples of that multi-core machines we
all have multi-core machines on our
laptops data centers have hundreds of
thousands of machines and cell phones
right cell phones our computers and we
can do some kind of distributed
computing tasks on those things sensor
networks I'll talk about one okay so
what I want to claim is that the most
expensive part in time energy money
anything you want to measure is the
communication rather than the
computation so let's look at the kind of
standard communication architecture that
you have a machine you have basically a
bunch of machines and they're all
connected through one shared channel
Ethernet usually and there's two types
of communication you can do peer-to-peer
so from one machine to another and you
can do broadcast you can from one
machine tell all the other machines some
some information
and the interesting thing is that
broadcast takes about the same time as
peer-to-peer because it's really how
much time you need the channel and the
independent community the communication
time when you do broadcast is
independent on the number of receivers
okay the same is bandwidth very much
bandwidth is a little bit different I
mean here I'm talking about both
bandwidth and latency but I don't want
to get too much into it yeah at a
different level right so you can talk
about many other levels of communication
like the whole memory hierarchy is about
communication from slow memory to faster
memory to even faster memory GPUs have
everything has basically an i/o
bottleneck of some level so but I'm not
concentrating on that right now I am
concentrating on the standard kind of
situation where you have a bunch of
standard computers all connected through
Ethernet okay so there is a standard
model for dealing with it it's called
the bulk synchronous parallel model
which is what Valiant invented in 1990
and this is one part of theory that
really had a huge effect on practice so
MapReduce Hadoop spark they're all based
on that they're all based on this idea
and the basic protocol is those
following masternode distributes jobs to
workers workers work then the workers
sends the results back to the master and
then there is a barrier okay
so the master wait for all message
before starting its next iteration
and it's also called in more hardware
setups it's called barrier
synchronization okay so let's look a
little bit in more detail how this
behaves in real-time you have a master
and a bunch of workers and here is the
time arrow okay going from top to bottom
so in a single iteration of this bulk
synchronous the master broadcast to all
the workers some information each worker
does their work
and then the workers communicate back to
the master now the communication back to
the master cannot be done broadcast
because it's only to the master so you
do it
peer-to-peer and that can take a long
time because you cannot only one this is
a shared shared resource the channel
okay so if you have this machine
communicating back and then this machine
communicating back and then this one and
then this one finally this one okay you
have to basically make that as a
sequential thing that's just the way
things are designed okay so so there's
two problems here one is that this is
statistical so workers don't start
exactly at the same time and they don't
take elect exactly the same time the
second one is that all workers has to
communicate back to the to the master
before continuing
so what slows down barrier sink
parallelization there are two
essentially two combined problems one is
called the laggards problem which is
that when you have a large number of
machines one of the machines will be
much slower than the others it's just
the way things are and so you have to
wait till the slowest one finish it
before you can go to the next iteration
while the other ones are just doing
nothing the other is the bandwidth
problem which is that collecting the
results back to the master before
continuing to the next iteration
requires point-to-point communication
from each worker and so the
communication time increases linearly
with the number of workers and this
actually quickly dominates computation
time so I've been actually working with
in kind of things and I was initially
really amazed I would look at my cluster
computing as fast as it can and then I'm
looking at the CPU how loaded they are
and they're loaded it like 5% so this is
I believe the reason okay so what I'm
going to suggest here is a new protocol
that is trying to basically improve on
DSP there's going to be no
synchronization there's going to be no
master there's going to be no
peer-to-peer it's going to be the only
broadcast okay so let's start with a
very simple example
suppose we have n coin and most of the
coins are unbiased half-and-half and one
or some of the coins are biased half -
gramma have flat grammar and our goal is
to find the biased coin so if we using
the synchronized model the the border
boundary synchronized we have computer J
flips coin J so we give each computer a
coin and and oh-oh even I'm sorry I
should first of all I want to basically
describe the the the not so good way to
do it which would be that every computer
does a mini batch like flips a coin some
n time and then communicates the sum to
the master and the master decides that
would be the batch method with the
problems that I said here is the method
that is completely different and unseen
from unsynchronized so the computer J
flips coin J and generate this binary
sequence and then it uses this test so
after each flip it checks whether the
sum of the x i's absolute value is
larger than some alpha plus beta T and
if that happens then it's broadcast to
everybody here I found the coin nothing
what would J if the number is the coin
is the index of the coin or the computer
each computer has a coin okay so
basically they're all searching and once
one of them finds it says I got it
send it up okay so how do you analyze
this this is based on wall sequential
test so if you have a binary sequence
like this random coin flips
then you have this log ratio test that
well designed and you can show unlike
sheriff bounds that basically work for a
particular time step and it and of
course you can expose a spread Delta and
so on but this is a very simple test
that that is guaranteed to make a
mistake only with probability Delta
right so how does this look how does it
look in practice it looks something like
this so here I have groups of coins coin
flips
this one is unbiased this one is biased
with P 0.6 and this one is biased with p
zero point no this is not oh yeah P zero
point six so it's zero point one more
than a half this is P of 0.7 and this
line is the wall test okay so what is
the advantage of wall test is that yes
it will not accept something with bias
with high probability it will not accept
this one and it will accept this one at
some point and it will accept this one
at some point but the main point to see
is if your bias is bigger then you'll
detect it sooner so you don't have to
decide ahead of time how many times
you're going to flip the coin it will
basically based on the assumption that
is inherent in in where you place this
line it will stop sooner if the bias is
bigger
there's no tuning face of the bias
there's no no there is a tuning based on
the base that's the slope of this line
and the slope of this line is basically
the bias that you're shooting for so
that's the minimum bias and then the
shift is how sure you want to be right
the more shift because at the beginning
you know you have like these things
going up and down so the shift is
basically how sure you want to be
just have a subject to having this
property that you do never wrong and
you're always right does this have the
minimal say expected stopping time well
it is the optimal rule in the sense that
it is it actually what it tested exactly
the log ratio so so so basically in what
sense can you say that it's optimal like
less than or equal to point five yeah
yeah
so it has yeah it has nice property
optimality properties you have any point
I mean between two alternatives I
understand the optimality but now you
have a right right right no that's true
so I need to impress what I need to to
correct for is I need to change the
shift of this so that it will count for
probability Delta over in so it's just
another shift here yeah is it possible
there's a nonlinear rule that has a very
expected stopping time I don't know the
answer to that I that there should be
nice my intuition is that there should
be a rule that behaves like square root
but I don't know I know about this rule
and it's proof is so extremely basic
fundamental that it seems like it would
be hard but but I don't really know
okay so what do we get from this the
timespan is the time to find the most
biased coin plus one broadcast okay but
this is good for what so it's actually
the basic step in boosting right so if
you think about it it's exactly what
boosting does and this is a way to do
distributed a synchronous boosting okay
so let me let me talk about that
so either boost in each iteration you
have to find a weak hypothesis and you
add it with some weight to the sum and
then yuri weight the example and the
weak hypothesis is exactly this the
error of h minus 1/2 is equal to gamma
which is larger than zero okay so so
this is exactly a bias point
so
so how am I going to do this so first of
all initialization each worker receives
a training set the simplest case is just
they all receive the same training set
and each run a worker randomly permute
the order of the training data that's
important because if you want to do
sequential analysis you want to assume
that it's iid are exchangeable all right
so then each worker is responsible for a
subset of the rules so if you think
about rules used in like boosting stamps
they're basically you have a vector of
some n features you can give each of the
workers one feature you're in charge of
finding weak rules for that feature so
it's set so they're looking at
differences okay so so initial weights
that you put our uniform and initial
rule strong rule is empty and then for
each worker you have at the
initialization after the initialization
a set of weak rule that it is in charge
of and a sequence of example and then
the algorithm itself is you initialize
some counter over the example then you
iterate and for any rule in the set of
rules that you're in charge of you set
the sum to zero and you repeat for each
rule you update with the weighted error
of that example okay
this is the V this is the error so it's
one if it's correct and minus one if
it's incorrect and then you just
multiply it by WI and then you just
cumulative this sum and then you compare
oh here I have a typo so you compare the
basically a stopping rule that says like
I said before alpha times T plus plus
gamma as alpha times T plus beta and
then if that rule fires you basically
set the new weak rule to HT and then and
broadcast that information to all of the
other computers and what do you do if
this loop is okay you update I and you
repeat this until either this machine or
some other machine found the wick rule
once anybody found a weak rule you
basically update strong reweighed your
examples you don't really need to
rewrite them you just need to update the
weighting function and repeat that's all
yes it just finding a biased coil is
business so what if you wanted to find
the most biased coin that probably would
take more communication right I mean
because in order to know if yours is the
most biased coin then you need to know
what are the other biased coins and the
most size is likely to find her first
right right right I do I do expect that
but it's not exactly that it's like the
most by it I mean you have your
assumption on bias and then you have
that for any assumption the the most the
most bias is likely to fire first so
it's a kind of a weaker guarantee yeah
you want to run multiple wall tests in
parallel with several different goals
you have one goal your comma right you
know okay okay so that's a very good
question and it has to do with the with
the tuning how do you want to tune so so
as I said I'm not so concerned with
computational complexity but more with
come with with communication complexity
so how to choose this decision of where
to send so I have a suggestion this is
kind of going from the other side right
so if you set this Delta to be larger
then then you get stronger your when you
get something you get a stronger
hypothesis but you might not get
anything and so it will take you a
longer time to find the weak hypothesis
right and you can get fewer broadcasts
per second right so it all depends on
what is your bottleneck so in my
experience the bottleneck is the
communication not the computation so
what you do instead is that you adapt
Delta according to the communication
load right if the basically it's kind of
like this this is each computer is
trying to tell everybody else something
new okay right trying to find something
new to say now if it is basically
listening to the to the channel and
everybody is speaking all the time then
it says well maybe I shouldn't talk so
quickly I mean I should find something
really new to say right so that's that's
the intuition
okay so you start with some Delta and
then each worker probes the network and
if the load is low it decreases Delta
and if the load is high increases Delta
now this is I'm sorry this is this this
Delta is like a reminiscence from a
previous version that I thought that the
threshold should be fixed that it's
actually a slope but but the same thing
holds all right so this is the tell me
something new model right so basically
computers are not just sending
information they're really sending
statistically significant information
right so they're basically sending only
stuff that when they have the reason to
believe that other computers will might
find it useful okay so here is the
general model each worker stores a state
so it has a state the machine has a
state the state basically represents a
distribution if you talk about it in
statistical terms it represents the null
distribution the null distribution is
what we believe the distribution is
without any further evidence each worker
searches for an alternative hypothesis
that is significantly better than this
hypothesis right so we have a current
belief state and we're looking for
something that is significantly better
and we can check locally that it's
significantly better we don't need to
talk with anybody about that and you
broadcast when the worker finds an
alternative hypothesis that is
significantly better it's broadcast that
information so everybody I'm telling
this information now thinking a little
war one of the big problems in
distributed computation is actually
reliability right so what if something
here goes wrong what if you know one of
them falls asleep and then wakes up a
year later and then has an idea okay
everybody listen to me this is the best
the best model ever so then I decided to
add
this thing that they take all due
diligence so before so a model there is
some kind of balance here between
between how much communication and due
diligence but the basic idea here which
is not exactly what I did in the
boosting case is that you just transmit
the whole state the whole model right so
it's the strong hypothesis that you're
some transmitting and while there I
submitted just the last additional okay
there is an advantage to transmitting
the whole model because that's what I
call new diligence you get your you're
working on your stuff and then somebody
says okay I have a great model for you I
have a new update you want to make sure
that it's really good before you accept
it so right the model that you receive
might be stale it might be from one hour
ago okay so before accepting the new
model the the worker compares its
performance with its current no it's
kind of says okay I have my model this
is the model I can compare on my data
how well they they perform and I'm going
to accept it only if it's really better
it's not better I'm not going to accept
it
so I call it probably approximately the
best just a name okay
right so justjust I'm going to talk
about it a little bit more in a minute
but you can think in distributed
learning that actually each worker
observes a slightly different
distribution and so some of from some of
the other workers it wants to get the
knowledge from others it doesn't want to
get the knowledge just because it's
different okay so some more examples of
TMS changes so you see that it's not
just something I invented for boosting
although I did but yeah so k-means plus
plus I apologize for the lack of
references I realized they should have
had many more references but how many
people here know k-means plus plus
everybody ok great so and then I'll tell
you about stochastic gradient descent
and then about sensor networks okay so
parallelized k-means plus plus you have
the caming plus flux methods like an
initialization for k-means but it has
theoretical guarantees so you have a
data set and what you basically do is
you pick a random point to initialize
the set up representative and then you
define a potential for each point which
is I don't know why this move there but
potential why is the minimum over X of
the distance between x and y are squares
okay that's the potential and then you
repeat so basically the
so so basically this potential you you
have a distribution that is the
probability that's proportional to this
potential and that's the probability
with which you accept the point and you
repeat oh yeah something here got
switched this was okay so now what would
be streaming k-means plus plus so
usually k-means flood plus is defined
just in the batch setting you define a
distribution over all of your instances
and then you pick but you can easily do
it in a streaming way right you randomly
permute the data and you initialize and
then you define the potential in the
same way and then you repeat basically
you go through the example and for each
example you compute the minimum of some
alpha times the potential and one right
and then you pick a point according to
this probability you just continue going
on and the question is how to adjust
alpha so you basically want to adjust
alpha so that the probability that alpha
times the potential of Y is larger equal
to one is small but not zero right so
you want basically to use the full range
if you basically make them all small
then then you're throwing away too many
examples okay so now that we have this
it's pretty clear how to make it tell me
something new kind of model
so first of all initialization at the
initial steps of k-means so I've been
running k-means on really very very
large data set so initial steps of
k-means there is no point to parallel
life because you accept points so
quickly that that you might as well just
run it all on one machine then you get
into the into some stage where the
average time between accepts is large is
large right so basically the points that
you have are such good representative
that you only get a new representative
every thousand iterations or every
million iteration okay
so so at that point you have it this
initial set of representative that is
broadcast to all workers and the workers
basically do the same process as before
but rather than just accepting the the
point and adding it you broadcast the
point so I found a point that broadcast
it to everybody else and and basically
then you if if you got the point to Z
either by yourself or by somebody
broadcasting it you add it to yourself
okay yes the other workers have done
some work until they received a new
point so right so away all the
computation they have
their work was just throwing things up
so whatever they I mean they're defining
stuff that they realize that useless
yeah they realize it uses I mean it's
not because of the broadcast they
decided it's useless they're searching
for a good thing they decide okay so can
you use this for stochastic gradient
descent so this is some work with my
student former student actually about
super money this is just a one slide 1
slide because don't have all of the
details worked out completely but
basically each worker computes a running
sum of single example gradients right if
you know about the mini batch approach
to doing stochastic gradient descent
each one of the machines calculate the
Sun sends it to the master then the
master combines all of these sums make a
step send the new state back to the
machines this is different ok so this is
basically all of the machines
essentially have the same the same
vector the same current set of weights
which is the state ok and they're
looking for a better state ok but here
they're just looking for a good gradient
so what does this look like we want to
identify if it's a statistically
significant gradient that's actually
quite possible here the null hypothesis
that we have zero gradient and and and
one thing that we need to assume it for
for at least the simple result is we
assume that we don't allow the gradient
to be more than some constant let's say
one so then it looks something like this
you have a true gradient and you have
like a random walk that is drifting to
in this direction but it's also
diffusing it's also random walk ok
so you can basically use a very simple
rule like before if use the sphere of
radius alpha plus beta T once your walk
is outside of that sphere that grows
with T then you know that you have the
gradient and then you broadcast a trade
or you broadcast the new state after the
gradient was added so so this I actually
plan to to implement soon and see if we
can actually get because not this is now
in in deep neural networks I mean this
is the method of choice right so so it
would be interesting if this can do
things faster the different workers are
basically working with a different
random permutation of the same data
let's say
so each orchid needs to have access to
the full Betazoid
yes yes yes I I know that that we worked
a lot on like how do partition the data
set in my experience that is not the
problem having multiple copies of the
data that's not the problem the problem
is that if you have a huge amount of
data to bring it to the CPU through the
memory hierarchy that takes you a lot of
time why Oh No okay so there's always an
initialization that you can't avoid
initialization so so yeah in this case
the initialization is essentially all of
the machines gets all of the data again
it's broadcast so if you broadcast okay
so now I want to do like a little bit of
an extrapolation go away from just nice
theoretical results and talk about
sensor networks so
suppose we have a cameras or along a
highway for monitoring traffic actually
do have cameras or anything and the
energy is limited and the cameras are
often powered by small solar panels
that's that's actually effect and again
it's communication not the data capture
or computation that is the main power
drain
so to basically communicate from one of
these cameras back to headquarters that
actually takes a lot of energy a lot of
bandwidth and a lot of energy so
strangely when I when I was searching
for images for this I actually ran into
this phone app in Florida that does
actually stream all of the cameras in
Florida per phone so it's kind of
interesting right I mean it's like this
highly detailed image is on your phone
and you're driving on the highway and
you're going to choose your route so
according to that I don't know so so
yeah yeah it's kind of amazing so I'm
suggesting not to do that yeah so okay
so what would be my approach to doing
this exact same thing each camera stores
a model of the traffic it seems right so
there's a model right I mean basically
how does the road look I mean the camera
looks always in the same direction
pretty much you can have the same the
same model how it looks at 10:00 in the
morning how it looks at 10:00 at night
how it looks you know all of these
things so that's all stored in the
camera then you have car detectors
classifiers that maybe somebody
initialized but you kind of trained them
on your data and then you have the
distribution of traffic like number and
velocity is a function of time of day
and day of week right there is in this
place there's always a traffic jam
between four and six thirty
okay so that's not news right so that
the camera doesn't really need to send
that and distribution of cart ID cetera
et cetera okay so the camera reports
back changes in the model right so
basically it sees over a long period of
time that there's a gradual increase in
traffic chase an increase speed
distribution construction and so on okay
so so it basically has a model the model
changes over time and it's basically
sends this model out when it knows that
it's significantly changed now there are
other cameras in its area let's look at
a very similar highway so they would
actually it would be useful for them to
know what that camera thinks and then
its reports of course the outliers so
the outliers is what you usually really
care about you don't care to know okay
there's again you know on i-95 a traffic
jam and now it's 5:00 p.m. and there's a
traffic jam again you want to know if
there's a gradual increase in traffic
changes in distribution outliers like a
traffic jam at an unexpected time or an
accident or a car parks on the side of
the road or a speeding car those are
outside of your model and so those you
might want to send back alright so you
minimize how much you're sending back
okay so going back to theory what what
does it mean for theory so this is a
challenge for you all because I have no
idea so Turing machines are sequential
that's a sack and we're used to saying
the parallel Turing machines can be
reduced to a Turing machine but that's
really only in the synchronized case all
right if they're not synchronized mmm
I don't know I just don't know so
so my question to you all is can we have
a theory of computation where both
computation and communication are
restricted a kind of high-level question
I don't know the answer and I want to
plug in something because I think that
it's becoming more and more relevant and
I think more people should look at it is
queueing theory so the goal in queueing
theory is characterize and analyze the
behavior of a shared resource so exactly
what we're talking about we have a
shared network and we want to analyze
what's really going to happen on this
network and things are not exactly what
you expect ahead of time like for
instance if you have a few where the
expected time is the time to serve
request is lower then is higher than the
sort that is lower than the time between
requests you'd think in the expected
level it's going to be fine
but in queueing theory shows you that if
you have heavy tails which is not an
uncommon thing it is not fine it
actually will have infinite delay so the
expected delays internet okay so that in
what I'm talking about the msn the
shared resource is the communication
channel and so this is a book I highly
recommend more hard core bells there
from CMU she is doing she comes from
theoretical computer science and she is
now one of the leaders in thinking about
queuing theory in the design of large
computers I think that to do parallel
computation without queuing theory is
very very nice
summarize so I want hope I convinced you
at least some of you that communication
is the new frontier insisting on
synchronization and common state is
often expensive and unnecessary jmsn
assumes that the data is generated by a
slowly varying distribution so it's a
strong assumption but it's an assumption
that holds a lot in real life if you
have a distribution it's slowly varying
but it's still almost iid on the short
scale you communicate only the
information that is new and surprising
implications and relevant to this is
queueing theory now one thing that I'll
just end with that I think is kind of
intriguing is how can you relate how can
you use this for privacy right we're
sending much much much less information
maybe if we're sending so much less
information we can protect the privacy
right so maybe it's a potential way of
getting to privacy through improving
some other things thank you yes this
point earlier I guess sale adviser but I
wrote a paper last year showing that the
right way to be doing this sequential
IPOP successes is using the law business
as logical which give you a boundary of
constant plus square root T log log T
and all this shows all that this shows
is that I don't talk with actually
enough right so it's not I definitely
going to use that it's worked with him I
just you know when I was preparing the
talk I didn't remember that so that's
all no so definitely we're going to use
that so that was the answer to your
question right is there a better
boundary so they prove the better
boundary
more sequential icon suspense with
optimal focus on simple versus simple
hypotheses steady kv-1 how can composite
that is beautiful alpha to be greater
than us
haha then it's no longer going to be
optimal and I don't think it is because
you know going table that it stops at
the right time adaptively
using square will be log of the UK so it
for anyways for any bias for any gamma
then it will stop after like 1 by delta
square it is icy
alright so things are much much better
than I knew but I yeah maybe we should
talk what I think which is up no I'm
sure he has I'm sure he has I don't
listen very well so yeah
[Applause]